as students and families soak up those
last few days of summer before the new
school year starts tutors say many
students actually use summer break to
catch up on their skills victoria saha
spoke with one local tutor who says she
saw an uptick in students this summer
entering a new grade can come with a mix
of emotions new classmates new teachers
and new topics to learn but for some
students perfecting skills from the
previous year was a priority before
tackling on something new i felt like
you know with this added little tutoring
all of a sudden they're gaining that
confidence gabriella corantello is a las
vegas elementary school teacher but also
tutored students throughout summer which
kept her very busy our biggest benefit
of summer tutoring is it helps bridge
the gap so it helps fill in the gaps
of knowledge from the previous school
year the 2021 to 2022 school year was
the first full year students were back
in classrooms for in-person learning
since the pandemic and quarantilo says
for some fundamental skills were
compromised during virtual learning
which students are still catching up to
they got so used the computer would just
automatically you know capitalize i and
they know how to realize like i'm like
you need to write a capital i
so that was something that was for me a
shocker another shocker for her was
noticing students struggling with
handwriting as virtual learning meant a
lot of typing or recording assignments
victoria saha live local now corantello
says although most schools offer after
school tutoring parents can also play a
big part at home she suggests making
learning assignments fun for example
when it comes to reading figure out
where your child's favorite spot is at
home instead of giving them a location